and now for a bit of fun here's math
meme review
with grant sanderson aka three blue one
brown
that we did after the recently released
podcast conversation
that you should check out and also thank
you to our sponsors
doordash dollar shave club and cash app
click the links in the description to
get a discount and to support this
podcast
here we go i i don't know if i actually
know what the goal of a meme review is
but i'll just give it to you all right
so on calm down calm down a plus
just what do you make of the absurd fact
that when you divide by zero that's not
allowed that breaks the universe and
my review is that the um devils in the
upper right quadrant
aren't nearly appreciative enough of uh
projective geometry
so that's that's my review of them
it's been uh this oh yeah okay this is
the machine insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again expecting
different results
machine learning is doing it over and
over again but bigger yeah
and so sometimes uh you know quantity
has a quality all of its own
uh yeah scale just like with gpg3
there's some magic
that happens yeah yes einstein didn't
have 175 billion parameters that's
interesting that's my review of that
meme this one whatever numbers you think
whenever you think you know numbers uh
my review is it's not sufficiently
not sufficiently mindful of diversity
concerns and how the periodics are
consistently underrepresented in
people's
conception of what the different number
systems are so i think it's uh
i'm going to say narrow-minded is my
review of that one
all right you study college level math
yes i am almost done with my bachelor's
degree
so you know a lot of math uh this one is
uncomfortably true
this is to our point as when you uh get
your degree in math there's a lot left
to know
[Music]
that's not even it's hard
[Laughter]
oh my god i think there's a
what is that i think that's a fish
eating a cat
no so it's a cat eating a fish and then
the uh the fish eating the cat
so i just have to say a plus this should
be in every algebra textbook
that's my meme review
i poured beer into square glass now i
just have beer
tired not impressed not impressed
uh engineering we've got mythbusters and
such physics
oh this is for our discussion yes
there's no this is a part of discussion
no one thinks that you could popularize
math um
so it ends with a that's that is
insightful
poignant so do you think it's pos so do
you think
there's it could be a cosmos for
mathematics
yeah i i actually i think there's huge
appetite for it i think number five
proves this fact
and and you're trying i mean that's true
but there's not for some reason
that do you think there will be a
netflix show one day with uh
if anyone on netflix is watching this i
will host it for you
you just call me but do you think you
could have um
like a general public kind of show like
cosmos and do math 100
i i i think it wouldn't be easy um
because you know you've got this tight
line between are you doing it
substantively or you're just waving your
hands
i think there's enough really
interesting math that you can
substantively get across
and i do think there's a pretty big
appetite for it um
the reason i say number file isn't just
the number file is great but the brady
has like 10 projects
of very similarly styled channels and
number file is the biggest among them by
far but they're all successful
they're all successful but i would have
guessed if you were just pitching these
products you know like 10 years ago like
oh the channel on physics will be very
popular the chemistry one will be pretty
popular
the numbers one i don't know some people
that might be like third or something
but the idea that the one about math is
the most popular of his channels by far
even though they're similar styles i
does
it does i do think speaks to the fact
that there is a
unsatiated appetite for real
a real understanding of what gets
mathematicians going and
i think a netflix type entity might
recognize that
you heard it here netflix
uh half off haircuts uh
oh it's getting uh shaved it's
every time it's it's shaving half of the
remaining hair
[Laughter]
that's uh great i love it it's kind of
brilliant that's my review
no substantive descriptions just i love
it um oh i actually saw this one
yeah co-teaching singing co-singing you
deserve to be quiet over there
who needs you oh you don't give them the
love you do you think sin cosine tangent
so you make the calculus of like tangent
look a little bit more compact while
kind of be confusing to
every single calculus student there
that's like wait what was secant again
just write it as one over cosine squared
it's not that many more symbols you're
contributing to the problem well thank
you for doing the most absurd
thing i probably have ever done you
probably have ever done
i appreciate it
you